في اوكرانيا ضاقت دائره المواجهه بين
بوتين وازينينسكي الرجلان وقف على اكثر
جبهتين محتزنتين في الحرب الرئيس الروسي
قام بزياره النادره هي الاولى له منذ ثلاث
سنوات الى بيلاروسيا التي تثير قلقا
عالميا كبيرا في حال دخولها على خط
المواجهه بينما فاجا الرئيس الاوكراني
الجنوده على اكثر الجبهات اشتعالا وهي
ضخمه زيارتان تحملان ربما رمزيه لكل طرف
من حيث الرسائل التحذيريه التي تندر بان
الفتره القادمه مفتوحه على مزيد من
التصعيد سينما بعدها تهديدات بوتن اليوم
باستخماله باستخدام اعمال تكتيكيه جديده
في اوكرانيا قد تكون بيلاروسيا هي المنطلق
ما هو التكتيك الجديد لا نعلم لكن عموما
سنعرف غدا اكثر عن خطط روسيا العسكريه
للعام المقبل التي سيعلنها بوتين في
اجتماع مع كبار القاده العسكريين وذلك
توقع لترامب
[موسيقى]
الوضع صعب جدا بهذه الكلمات وصفا بوتين
على الوضع في المناطق الاربعه التي ضمتها
موسكو مؤخرا كلماتهم قليله لكنها تحمل
الكثير من الرسائل في ثناياها موسكو لا
تبدو راضيه على تطورات التطورات الميدانيه
رغم اعلانها ضمن جمهوريات دونيس لوجان
وكذلك من طاقتي زبرجه وخيرسون التي سحبت
منها اخيرا
كما ان رسالتها بوتين حملت ايضا تلميحا
الى استمرار التهديد الاوكراني على هذه
المناطق من خلال دعوته الاجهزه
الاستخباراتيه الى التركيز اكثر من اجل
حمايه السكان هذه المناطق واصفا اياهم
بالمواطنين الروس
ربنا
صعب للغايه الناس يعلقون الامال عليكم ومن
واجبنا حمايتهم وضمان سلامتهم واحترام
حقوقهم من جانبنا سنواصلوا تعزيز قواتنا
في تلك المناطق بالمعدات العسكريه
من جديد حول امكانيه دخول انس في الحرب
الاوكرانيه
حول امكانيه دخول طرف ثالث دخوله الى
غماره هذه الحرب وهذه المره في مواجهه
اوكرانيا
الولايات المتحده الدعم الاول لاوكرانيا
اعربت عن قلقها بعد هذه الزياره حيث اوضحت
السكرتيره الصحفيه للبيت الابيض كان نجم
كير ان واشنطن لطالما شعره بالقلق من دور
بيلاروسيا في الحرب ويتردد الحديث منذ
اشهر حول امكانيه مشاركه بيلاروسيا بشكل
مباشر في الحرب في اوكرانيا الى جانب
روسيا غير ان الموضوع ظل مجرد تكه هناك
حتى الان على الاخر